Watching a movie at home just can't match
the experience of seeing it on the big screen.
Plenty of films are just fine to watch on
your home theater or portable device of choice,
but every year brings a new crowd of releases
that really need the big screen to be truly
appreciated.
Here's a look at some of the biggest 2018
movies that demand to be seen in theaters.
First Man
In First Man, Damien Chazelle
is following up 2016's La La Land with a period
piece about the Apollo 11 moon landing.
Starring Ryan Gosling as the legendary Neil
Armstrong, it looks to be a riveting drama
that will shine like a star on the big screen.
Chazelle shot select scenes with IMAX 70 millimeter
film, and that's the way he intends for First
Man to be seen.
The film revolves around the most famous lunar
mission of all time, and the Apollo 11 launch
and subsequent landing on the moon is going
to look absolutely spectacular on a massive
screen.
The Predator
Writer/director Shane Black is responsible
for some of the better action movies in recent
memory.
Considering this, The Predator is going to
be a must-see in theaters.
Few genres play as reliably well in theaters
as action and horror.
A big screen brings out the true power of
explosive action, and an audience amplifies
the experience of seeing a horror movie.
The Predator looks to have everything we love
about going to the movies wrapped up in one
neat package.
Creed II
2015 saw the Rocky franchise make an unlikely
comeback with Creed, which shifted the focus
from Rocky Balboa to the son of his old rival
Apollo Creed.
The film nabbed a ton of critical acclaim,
all while telling an emotional, visually striking
story.
“Come on!
Don’t sit there!”
“They’re trading shots in the kind of
back-and-forth action that most of us didn’t
expect to see.”
The journey of Adonis continues in Creed II,
and you don't want to miss it in theaters.
Seeing a Rocky movie on the big screen with
an excited crowd is a special experience that
doesn't come around too often.
Halloween
Few cinematic boogeymen have delivered big-screen
scares quite as effectively over the years
as Michael Myers, and now he's back in a brand
new Halloween movie.
Directed by David Gordon Green of Pineapple
Express fame and co-written by his frequent
collaborator Danny McBride, the film sees
original protagonist Laurie Strode come back
to take on the man who ruined her life.
It looks to be a return to form for the series,
and with the greatest slasher villain of all
time returning to cinemas for the first time
in nearly a decade, you don't want to miss
the chance to see Halloween on the big screen.
Venom
Spider-Man's goth symbiote twin makes his
solo big-screen debut in Venom, and this is
definitely one you need to see in a theater.
Director Ruben Fleischer has put together
a twisted, brutal, and witty take on the popular
Marvel anti-hero.
Aside from the great cast led by Tom Hardy,
the effects look killer, and with an IMAX
release to accompany its standard theatrical
run, you aren't going to want to miss Venom
at a theater near you.
"Eyes.
Lungs.
Pancreas.
So many snacks, so little time."
Bohemian Rhapsody
Generations of Queen fans will never get to
see Freddie Mercury perform live, but Bohemian
Rhapsody may be the next best thing.
The bio-pic surveys the rise of Queen, including
multiple concert recreations, but the big
draw here is the famous shows at Wembley Stadium.
Bohemian Rhapsody gives fans a chance to sit
in a theater and see a re-enactment of Queen's
biggest concerts of all time on a massive
screen.
Tragically, that's about as close as anyone
can get to seeing Mercury tear up the stage
today.
Aquaman
Jason Momoa's take on the King of Atlantis
is one of the strongest elements in the DCEU
so far, and the full-length film starring
the aquatic hero looks absolutely amazing.
Add in a killer cast that includes Patrick
Wilson, Nicole Kidman, and Amber Heard, and
Aquaman feels like it could be something special.
All that said, the visual spectacle of Atlantis
itself could end up stealing the show.
The first trailer gives us a tantalizing glimpse
of the lush underwater kingdom, filled with
beautiful design and color.
It remains to be seen whether Aquaman will
be an aquatic slam dunk, but a killer cast,
Atlantis, and more Momoa is enough to make
it a must-see at your local cineplex.
"I hear you can talk to fish."